okay Rena wrote in saying hey guys what
is the start of the week in your mind is
it Sunday or is it Monday I have a very
strong feeling on this the start of the
week is Thursday for me oh now I'm
kidding around
I consider the start of the week to be
Sunday and there's a couple reasons why
number one I like symmetry and if you
think about the week is starting on
Monday and ending on Sunday you
basically have a week that has the first
five days or weekdays and the last two
days are weekend days and that's very
non symmetrical in my mind I'm much more
like the idea of you have a weekend day
at the beginning of the week and you
have a weekend day at the end of the
week and in between sandwiched very
symmetrically I'm not OCD by the way you
have five weekdays so that is one reason
why I consider the start of the week to
be on Sunday there's one other reason
why I consider the start of the week to
be Sunday based on our payroll schedule
the end of the week is Saturday so when
I think of weeks in my mind like work
weeks
they also start on Sundays and lastly I
start my work on a week of shows on
Sunday afternoon or evening so for me
it's sort of visually it's mentally
organized to say yeah sunday is the
beginning of the production week that is
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
so I feel very strongly that the start
of the week is Sunday yeah I mean it's
very subjective I would I would say that
the start of the week is Monday because
when I consider the weekend Saturday and
Sunday that that's the end of the week
then you go back to work on Monday and
start it all over again so in my mind
even though most American calendars we
see the start of the week on Sunday and
I would much prefer it to be changed to
Monday as the beginning of the week
that's interesting you're taking a
linguistic analysis which is it is
called the week end for a particular
reason which is that it's the end of the
week it's it's sort of uh it's beautiful
in its simplicity isn't it thank you
okay so I don't know that this really
matters but I say Sunday Pat says Monday
let me know your thoughts if you think
the if you think it's some other day
other than that I think Saturday is the
only other reasonable day that could be
argued which is
you start the week with the weekend but
I can't imagine anybody saying David
it's Tuesday you fooled me by saying
that you thought the beginning of the
week was Thursday though yeah maybe the
I don't know if this is worthy of a
david pakman.com poll question but if it
becomes hugely controversial we can do
it